[Musique]
c'est dans les locaux de la caisse
d'allocations familiales à sainte marie
que christelle du boss secrétaire d'état
a officialisé la recentralisation par
l'état de la gestion du rsa revenu de
solidarité active
dix mois après l'annoncé faite par la
ministre d outre-mer annick girardin
depuis une dizaine d'années c'est le
département qui s'était vu octroyer par
l'état la gestion du rsa
désormais la collectivité ne financera
plus le reste à charge qui s'élevait à
plus de 135 millions d'euros
un soulagement s'est amené au prix de
beaucoup d'efforts et aussi je dirais
parce que unanimement les élus du
département ont été avec moi sur ce
dossier et je salue le travail réalisé
par l'ensemble des vice présidents les
élus du département
le travail réalisé qui fait qu'à un
moment donné quand on parle ensemble du
même bois et bien on peut être écouté et
là aussi je salue par ailleurs mais tout
les coups qu'elle a reçus donc la part
des membres du gouvernement notamment du
président de la république tout
simplement pense qu'il fallait je dirais
sauver ce département de la réunion qui
a en charge les politiques sociales sur
son territoire de pouvoir assumer cette
responsabilité
imposer qu'on retrouve des moyens et ses
moyens on le retrouve à travers cette
recentralisation lutte contre
l'illettrisme la pauvreté l'échec
scolaire ou encore pérenniser l'emploi
pour les bénéficiaires du rsa
autant d'actions qui permettront
d'ouvrir de nouvelles perspectives pour
les familles réunionnaises
nous avons augmenté les minima sociaux
pour ceux qui ne peuvent pas reprendre
le travail qui ne veut pas travailler
les bénéficiaires du rsa potentiellement
sont des personnes qui quand on lève les
freins périphériques sont en capacité
d'aller au travail et donc on doit
améliorer cet accompagnement et c'est
tout le travail qui est en lien aussi
avec les entreprises c'est à dire que
les entreprises doivent faire ces
passerelles aussi vers le monde du
social quand on a des entreprises qui
disent mais moi je vais recruter mais je
n'arrive pas à recruter et viennent nous
rencontrer parce qu'on a aussi des
personnes qui sont accompagnés qui sont
formés et qui sont prêtes à aller
travailler et donc c'est bien par le
travail qu'on luttera contre la pauvreté
parce que quand vous retrouver
reprenez un travail d'abord vous pouvez
cumuler avec la prime d'activité en
fonction de votre situation vous avez
des ressources qui sont aussi augmenté
et de fait là c'était la collectivité
sera l'état qui financera plus le rsa
mais son épaule des moyens qu'on peut
mettre à disposition de politique
d'insertion prend compte continuer à
mieux accompagner ceux qui sont encore
dans la pauvreté
trente agents ont été recrutés par la
caisse d'allocations familiales pour
assurer cette nouvelle mission
certains agents du département rejoint
cette cellule le département et la cave
continuerons à travailler en étroite
collaboration pour permettre aux
bénéficiaires du rsa de s'inscrire dans
la voie d'une insertion durable
[Musique]